a very good morning to you
for the first time in nearly three
months lockdown restrictions in england
are being eased today with the end of
stay-at-home guidance
and a return of the rule of six outdoors
now it comes with a warning from the
government though to stick to the rules
and not be tempted to mix inside
well from this morning six people or two
households
even if the number of people is higher
can meet in a park or
public place or private garden as well
now outdoor organized sport can resume
as well
and it is officially the end of the stay
at home rule
although the government says people
should still work from home
where possible sadia chowdhury reports
for months in england we were told to
stay at home
from today that's a thing of the past
and no sooner had the rules been relaxed
they were teeing off in derbyshire
just the sort of dedication needed to
keep the nation
fit and healthy i've been off work the
last four out of five months so it's
nice just to get out the house and see
people and
yeah back to a bit of normality so it's
definitely the social side it's what
it's all about really
and the fact that you get to play golf
it's
a bonus fresh air dilutes the virus
particles
and can blow them away kovid recovery is
central to this message
and as restrictions ease an important
reminder
stay outside when you're with people not
in your household or bubble
nowhere better perhaps than a tennis
court
every court is booked from seven o'clock
until half past
eight in the evening the biggest
difficulty
is when conversations off-court get
strung out
we manage them on the courts and then as
soon as they leave
push they rush together
in some parts of the country tennis
court bookings are up by a reported 500
percent
and with lockdown easing that trend is
set to continue
and not just in tennis our green spaces
have seen an
unprecedented number of visitors not
without consequences
we are having areas of grass that are
being a little bit
damaged by the footfall so we ask people
to try and stick to paths wherever they
can
we ask people even to maybe stagger
their visits to the park to different
times of day
today's hot weather comes with a plea
from the metropolitan police to not get
complacent
and a promise that they will hand out
fines
sadia chowdhury sky news
well the backdrop to england's looser
lockdown is another set of figures which
suggests the pandemic is still
slowly subsiding in the uk the latest
figures show
3862 new cases have been reported
with 19 more deaths recorded that takes
the total number of people who've died
within 28 days of a positive test
to 126 592.
the figures also confirm another vaccine
record
with more than 30 million first doses
now given well let's talk to our
reporter ashley huranag who's one
outdoor swimming pool in london that has
reopened
literally just reopened this morning
ashland i see
people in the pool already
they really are you've got some real
eager beavers this morning stephen today
does absolutely feel like the stepping
down off another rung of the lockdown
ladder if i move out the way you can
take a look at
some of those who are taking full
advantage of that today the with the
weather turning today and restrictions
being eased today
at the tooting lido it's expected to be
quite busy we've got 60 people
per session every session is booked out
today that means about 360 people are
going to come down
eager to get in that water which i have
to say is a balmy 9.6 degrees it's the
largest freshwater pool in england
and this of course is one of many
outdoor sports which are resuming today
it's not just swimmers but
climbers golfers uh tennis players alike
for that long-awaited taste of freedom
that stay home
to stay at home order it does of course
lift as well today
it's likely we're going to see day
trippers and tourists resuming not only
coming down to places like this but also
local landmarks perhaps the park for
instance you can now meet up to
six people in a group of six or two
households can mix together
in someone's garden it's likely though
that with the enthusiasm of today
there will of course be some element of
caution too
as the prime minister has always said
the success of today has come down to
the vaccination rollout
but the caution will come because we
know what can happen
when restrictions ease and it's hoped
there won't be consequences to follow
and tourism good to see you
this morning minister let's talk about
sport first and foremost
a lot of people wanting to get back to
sport exercise is a key thing of course
but how difficult is it to make sure
that this is all carried out
in a safe a covered safe way
well of course uh today's a really big
day for millions of people across the uk
just
dying to get back to the things that
they love and we've seen that already in
your piece just there i mean the minute
that the
locations are opening people are there
um but they're taking the
responsibilities those opening up the
spaces really seriously we've covered
secure measures
and and then the grassroots sport as
well it's all within guidelines so
those who are running these events know
what they need to do
and they're doing so very responsibly so
i'm very confident things will open
safely
but on the on the wider issue and just
meeting people in the rule of six or the
two families situation in a
public place or or a private garden um
how difficult is that going to be to
police because we know when
restrictions were eased at the end of
last summer
we saw lots of people gathering and
perhaps not surprisingly so
how do you expect people to stick to the
rules this time
well first of all i think we can trust
in the common sense of the british
public to a very great degree the vast
majority of people
absolutely stick to the rules and
actually there's a fair bit of
self-policing that goes on as well
but indeed if there are breaches and the
police can intervene and fine
um and they'll continue to do so where
that's the case but the message very
clearly and hence the
uh the new message today actually is
making sure that it's very much about
outdoors and open space so these are
baby steps they're significant steps
but they're cautious baby steps in part
of the reopening plans and i say the
message is it's outdoors it's not
indoors yet
so please be sensible but the the
stay-at-home guidance
has gone so where does that leave people
in terms of saying
i mean my parents live in the lake
district could i travel to the lake
district
to visit them outside in their garden
and then come home again is that allowed
it is allowed but you're absolutely
right it needs to be
outside in the garden and i think if
people are traveling they need to think
very carefully about how they travel
where they fill up the petrol
if they need food and so on probably get
that locally before you go on the
journey
because what we don't want is people
intermixing um
in different parts of the country to any
greater degree than necessary and then
when you do go and visit a friend or a
relative
make sure you stay in those gardens or
stay outdoors and obey those rules so
please just again be sensible
yeah but that does involve common sense
and of course the great british public a
lot of us have
common sense but when it comes to
policing the rules
that makes it very difficult for the
police doesn't it when
when people are using their own common
sense their own initiative
you know how do police police it
well it's i mean it is a combination
isn't it because i mean of course the
police are there to implement the law
and there are still laws here and they
will uh implement fines so if there's
large gatherings again remember it's a
rule of six and
up to six but only six or two households
so if the police see people breaking
those rules they can intervene they can
break up
and say if necessary fine i i recognize
it's more difficult in people's private
gardens and that's why we're appealing
to people to be sensible
for the sake of their health and others
please don't break the rules they're
there for a reason
they're there for the public safety and
public health and i say the vast
majority of people do comply
and we really appreciate that as we move
forward though i mean this is
the first step and you said baby steps
we get that but of course it
it gives us all a little bit of hope me
included i've got to say
that come august we may get the chance
of a little bit of a summer holiday
is is that still a possibility or is
government ruling that out at this stage
the fact we might be able to hop on a
plane and
head to the continent well i think
there's two things there first remember
you can have a you can have a holiday
in the uk as well and i encourage people
to do that and plan for that as well
but indeed overseas travel uh the global
travel task force is reporting
um very soon actually and that will help
determine the parameters for
international travel
but you're right it's important not only
people getting on a plane and going
overseas but i'm also the
minister for tourism we want people to
come into the uk as well
inbound tourism is hugely important to
our economy
so on a global basis we're working with
our
other countries to make sure that we can
open up international travel but we'll
do so cautiously
i mean we have to bear in mind there's
all this talk of the third wave
across mainland europe but some experts
saying of course the third wave is
actually
the uk variant so we have to
tie all that in don't we into how we
make those decisions about augustine
further onwards well absolutely and
caution is the is the name of the game
here i mean we are seeing rises in
in europe there are actually you know
quite a few variants around the world
and we do have to keep a very close eye
on the variants in fact that's one of
the prime minister's stated tests so
we'll keep a close eye on variants
um but as i said we we do want to open
up as soon as we can that goes for
domestic and indeed international but
we'll do so cautiously
based on the evidence and we'll keep a
very close eye on what's happening
in both the eu and elsewhere around the
world
uh look from from talking about the the
positives
that we've seen you know or are seeing
from today onwards let's hope let's keep
our fingers crossed
it all follows the plan can we look at
what covid has done
over the past year because your
colleague former home secretary former
chancellor saji javid is publishing a
report today he's led in this report
about sexual abuse child sexual abuse
uh in england um particularly during the
the pandemic and seeing how that has
escalated he's talking about a number of
loopholes
that needs to be closed now i mean with
i know there's a lot of issues which
have been brought to the fore because of
the pandemic
but this one in particular is one that
has to be addressed and addressed
urgently isn't it
well i agree uh completely and my my
neighboring mp sajid we've got a lot of
a lot of time for him we'll listen very
carefully about what he and the report
has to say
it's absolutely that we take steps and
if there are loopholes uh then we'll
take action in the home office
and others will be uh keeping a very
close eye on this development
unfortunately
uh covert has not impacted directly
people's physical health
it's also opened up quite a range of
problems mental health and indeed
unfortunately
cases of abuse are more prevalent so
further action
uh will be taken there but alongside
his report we're getting all these very
concerning reports about what is
happening in in some
schools and people pupils and former
pupils who are coming forward to
allege incidents now they're being
investigated
we know but that raises some very real
questions doesn't it about how
these issues are addressed in our
schools
it does and immediately you'll be aware
that there is now a helpline uh to
anybody who's facing these
uh these kind of abuses uh so please do
call that helpline
um but but we will be looking at this
and of course the
uh ofsted uh and the inspectorate do
have powers up to and including closing
down schools if there's uh evidence
uh there so we will again be looking
very closely at this it's a quite
alarming picture that's been emerging
over the last few days
uh just an interesting one to throw at
you to finish minister there's a report
it's in the telegraph this morning but
reports saying and we've we've heard it
anecdotally
about the term bame black and
asian minority ethnic we use it when
we're talking about
uh some minority groups in the uk it's
become something we see each and every
day now i know i appreciate as
it would be for me it's difficult for
you to answer it in some respects
because we don't fall into those groups
but does this need to be looked at
because the reports are saying
you know that actually there are a lot
of people who fall under the bame
category
who just don't like it as terminology
they don't think it works they don't
think it represents them
do we need to look again well i haven't
seen the full report of the
of the commission but i think you're
right we've got to be sensitive to treat
people as individuals and sometimes
categorizations can be challenging or
indeed offensive even if they're not
intended to be so
uh but as i said i haven't seen the full
report yet we'll see what it has to say
um and then act accordingly okay
minister good to talk to you this
morning thank you
as well thank you well let's talk to our
political correspondent kate mccann
who's here
morning to you i mean look there seems
to be what the minister was saying about
the guidelines and the the rules being
eased from today
that it's a lot about common sense but
that still raises questions about how we
apply the rules and how we police the
rules
it does and i think what we're going to
be hearing a lot this week from
ministers is that note of caution you
heard it there
baby steps do everything you know little
and
you know each step little and often i
suppose if you like
you're allowed to go and see people in
your garden you're allowed to have two
households mixing but what the
government doesn't want to happen
is people going inside each other's
homes is people hugging is us all
feeling like you know freedom
of course we're going to see this
coincide with a heat wave this week
that's going to be slightly difficult
too what they want people to do is use
their judgment so one of the interesting
answers there in that interview was that
you are allowed to go and travel to see
your parents
in the lake district but you shouldn't
stop on the way you should prepare food
before you go
and of course you'd only be able to do
that outside but as you say that does
lead to some pretty big questions about
people traveling around the country to
beauty spots for example and maybe going
for a longer day out than they have been
allowed to before
and again some questions on policing so
i think the government message is going
to be about caution it's going to be
about outside it's going to be about
underlining the fact that yes
we can do more but we still can't do
everything and they hope
that people will follow those rules
because remember that plan relies on us
all doing that
and nothing changing in between now and
the next stage of unlocking
okay kate thank you now reports this
morning say
engineers have managed to partially
refloat a giant container ship stranded
in the suez canal
the ever given and its cargo have been
blocking the canal for
six days now salvage engineers say
there's still a long way to go but the
former chairman of the suis canal
authority has told sky news
he's confident it could happen soon the
ship
got stuck last tuesday initially diggers
were used to try to evacuate the bow of
the ship
on wednesday egyptian authorities used
tugs to try to
tow the ship to freedom two days later
specialist salvage and dredging
equipment was employed to try to refloat
the vessel
and on saturday tugs managed to move the
ship
30 degrees after tons of sand were
dredged more tugs have now arrived and
salvages hope to take advantage of a
full moon
and the resulting spring tide well let's
talk to
uh our correspondent alistair bunkel
who's in egypt
for us this morning look i mean the the
implications of this in terms of the
trade down the suez canal are absolutely
huge aleister
i mean how hopeful are they that this
may be the day when things start to get
moving again
no i think this is really good news and
if you look at some of the images
um that have started to come out
overnight
uh from the location on the suez canal
it does look as though
there's quite a sizable gap that's now
opened up
along the canal because we're all now
very familiar with that
particularly that top down image that
shows
the ever given diagonally across the
waterway blocking it completely
what they've managed to do in the early
hours of the morning using 10
tugs is pull it in four different
directions
and ease it out enough that it is
starting to point in the right direction
now
now having said that the
one of the senior people from the the
dutch rescue operation who are helping
the egyptians
was on dutch radio this morning saying
it's still not a piece of cake from here
on in those were his words
they're bringing down another tug later
today that they hope will be able to
pull it
completely free but there is still the
possibility that they'll need to offload
some of those shipping containers
on board the ever given in order to make
it lighter if that is the route they
have to go down then that's what could
be
quite lengthy that could delay it
further still having said that
given when we were late last night and
given where we were this morning
the ship is now certainly partially
refloated according to some reports it's
eighty percent refloated
and it is looking far more positive this
morning for the sewers canal being
opened up
very soon but what has the impact been
alistair on
on the suez canal being closed it's one
of the world's busiest waterways
being closed for best part of a week it
must have had a huge impact
huge impact i mean without any doubt
there will be items of furniture
clothing
like kids toys in your home
up and down the country that will have
passed through the sewers canal
making its way from the far east into
western europe it is a hugely busy
shipping lane
um that obviously most of us aren't
always aware that what we're buying in
shops in the uk or elsewhere has come
through that shipping lane
and so to close it really has
spotlighted
just how damaging it can be to the
global economy
it's been a week now for around 300 i
think last time about 369
cargo ships tankers as well because oil
and gas comes through there from
persian gulf they are now stacked up
waiting
to transit through if they have to
remove shipping containers and if it
takes much much longer
then the global impact will really start
to be felt
okay alistair for now thank you
that's all to come for you this morning
the taxi sharing company
uber will allow some uk customers to
request a zero emissions
car we'll talk to them at 7 45 this
morning
labor says a backlog in the court system
means convictions for some
serious offences have fallen to a
10-year low we'll talk to the shadow
justice secretary david lammy
just after eight o'clock and with so
little to enjoy during the lockdown are
you one of the people who's getting an
easter wreath this year we'll talk to a
florist who says
business is booming that's at 8 20.
now one person has been injured after
more airstrikes overnight in myanmar
pictures taken yesterday confirm reports
that about 3000 people have now left the
country heading for neighbouring
thailand
the foreign office has told all british
nationals in mayor mart
to leave also making the news for you
this morning in the uk
is facing an epidemic of child sex abuse
according to a report
co-authored by former home secretary
sajid javid
it makes nearly a hundred
recommendations for tackling abuse
warning that even before lockdown
governments and tech companies were
losing the war
and that the pandemic has created a
perfect storm for victims
and abusers officials in mozambique say
terrorists were responsible for
an attack in which dozens of people
including expatriate workers were killed
they're believed to have died during a
siege at a hotel in the town of palmer
the area is reported to have been under
attack by islamist militants
since wednesday
the defence and security forces have
regretfully recorded the loss of life of
a group of citizens
who rushed into a column of vehicles
leaving from the amarula hotel
and were ambushed by terrorists we
regret this loss of life
and inform you that we are continuing
our work to eliminate the terrorists
a group of parents whose children attend
battley grammar school have called for
calm after protests against a teacher
who showed a caricature of the prophet
muhammad the school has apologized and
the teacher involved has been suspended
the parents claimed staff failed to
appreciate how offensive the image was
we believe that in a democratic society
everyone holds a right to opinion and
expression
however we as parents and citizens
also believe that with these rights
come responsibility we as parents and
citizens
stand resolute that our children should
be able to
attend school without having their faith
which is protected in law
or their culture ridiculed insulted or
vilified
a judge has raised concerns over
government plans to hold
parole board hearings in public saying
they should be approached
cautiously hearings currently take place
in private but rob mckeon said the
effect
open hearings could have on victims must
be considered
thousands of people have flocked to
india's holy city of mathura to
celebrate the hindu festival of colours
restrictions around people gathering for
the festival were introduced after the
country reported over 62
000 new cases of coronavirus the biggest
jump
since october
the eyes of the world turned to the u.s
city of minneapolis today as a former
police officer goes on trial accused of
murdering
george floyd video of derek chauvin
kneeling on the 46 year old's neck for 8
minutes and 46 seconds last year
led to global protests and as sally
lockwood now reports the trial is being
hailed
as one of the most important in american
history
[Music]
[Applause]
george floyd's name has reverberated
around the world
but at the center of this story is a
family
in church with supporters ahead of the
trial
one way or another
their relative but a case for justice
shared by
millions who feel the floyd family is
standing for them
we are thankful to all the protesters
all the activists
everybody in america everybody around
the world who said
until we get justice for george floyd
none of us can breathe
prayerfully at the end of this trial we
can all exhale together
for george floyd give him the breath
that was denied to him by derrick
sheldon
a backdrop of heavy security sets the
stage for the trial at the courthouse in
minneapolis
a small group of activists making their
voices heard
peaceful and undeterred we want to walk
away from this feeling like
we won we want our work to pay off
and we want a guilty verdict for all
four officers that is what we want that
is why we're out here
the jury's job now begins hearing
opening statements
the prosecution will make its case first
and it's expected
we'll argue derek chovin's actions in
keeping his knee on george floyd's neck
for nearly nine minutes for a direct
cause of his death
the defense will seek to cast doubt on
those claims and introduce
evidence to suggest he could have died
from other factors
and that derek shovin didn't intend to
harm him
for many this trial will be a defining
moment for race relations
in america the outcome uncertain and the
stakes high
sally lockwood sky news minneapolis
well sky news will have full coverage of
the trial with continuous coverage of
the court proceedings streaming live on
our website
and app youtube and a special pop-up
channel
which you can find on sky 524
that's george floyd george floyd killing
the trial full coverage
on sky news throughout the day now
let's see what the weather's going to do
for you today naz is standing by
the big question i've got now is do i
need to get the shorts and the trunks
and the flip-flops out today
um you can do if you want to uh stephen
in fact over the next few days it's
going to get increasingly sunny
and warm and temperatures generally will
be above average for most places but
there will be wet and cold conditions
across the far northwest
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
very good morning to you so we're going
to see lots of sunshine developing over
the next few days
and it is going to become warm and
temperatures will then become
higher as well above average for many
areas over the next few days too in fact
it's a mild start this morning
across parts of the north in particular
but it's windy there there are spells of
rain across the northwest of the uk and
island two heaviest over the northwest
of ireland
and western parts of scotland elsewhere
it's
uh cloudy but largely dry start it's
already beginning to brighten up across
some southern areas although the south
coast probably staying quite cloudy for
much of the day and therefore cool and
you can see
that's evident with the temperatures too
but elsewhere across central and
southern areas by around midday i think
we'll see sunshine developing and then
across the rest of england and wales
through this afternoon but the north and
northwest of these areas i think will
still hold on to quite a bit of cloud
fairly cloudy for island northern
ireland later too but a bit of
brightness
and drier and the south and east of
scotland also seeing a bit of brightness
and warmth but the northwest has gotten
cloudy
and wet
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
naz thank you are still to come on sky
news breakfast we'll talk to
medical experts police and the manager
of an outdoor swimming pool
as the lockdown in england starts to
ease
only about half a mile from the turkish
coast and it's
evident that is the boat seriously
overcrowded
this is one of the most severe viruses
in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
that's it it got us then
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely
thin and very frail her arms look at her
arms i can
put my entire hand round
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
and once it takes a hold it's very very
difficult for these
firefighters to get a grip of it to get
on top of it and put it out
[Music]
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
fantastic
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so the government says people are now
allowed to travel around the country to
see their relatives following the easing
of lockdown rules in england
after nearly three months the
stay-at-home guidance has changed to
minimize travel but in the last hour the
sport and tourism minister nigel
hudderson told me
that people can travel to see family but
they must take precautions
and be aware of stopping on route
it needs to be outside in the garden and
i think if people are traveling they
need to think very carefully about how
they travel where they fill up the
petrol
if they need food and so on probably get
that locally before you go on the
journey
because what we don't want is people
intermixing
in different parts of the country to any
greater degree than necessary and then
when you do go and visit a friend or a
relative
make sure you stay in those gardens or
stay outdoors and obey those rules
so a bit more freedom for people in
england but is it the right move
at the right time well let's talk to
former world health organization
director professor anthony costello who
joins us now good to see you this
morning what do you think of the timing
well the government have laid out a road
map and obviously we need to get out of
lockdown the incredible
damage that that does economically i
mean there is some good news around
over well over half of all our
adults have been uh have had a first
dose of vaccine and the uptake rates
have been
uh much higher than people expected
these vaccines are very effective
deaths and hospital admissions have
fallen come right down
but there is still quite a lot of
caution around
as chris whittie said uh i think last
week that
uh seconds further surges are
are inevitable and all the models
predict surges later in the year and
and you may think why is that because
you would think as
vaccination becomes more complete we
would be getting out of this
but i think the concerns relate to the
numbers of people
who will remain unvaccinated
particularly amongst
younger age groups secondly the worries
about
variants of the virus you know we've had
the uk variant which increased death
rates and
um increased transmission and that's the
virus that's sweeping through europe
right now
uh we have a south africa variant which
may have some resistance
to the vaccine and uh and then the final
worry is if we get
new outbreaks will our test trace and
isolate
system be fit for purpose so in terms of
of that surge then if we are seeing a
surge in young people and i know
there have been cases of young people
who've suffered terribly with covid and
and some sadly who have died but the
majority seem to
fare a lot more a lot better than the
than the older or medically vulnerable
population
so are we can we handle a surge if
it happens
well
is to ally
as as higher coverage of vaccine as you
can get
with the public health measures that
will jump
on any surge as quickly as possible
and we are heading up with very good
vaccination figures
we still have to see whether the under
50s are going to
take it up as much as we as we would
like
and then of course the issue will be
later whether or not we also move to
vaccinate children or not
depending upon perceptions of whether it
is entirely safe or not
but the the worry is that in the past
we haven't had a system that's really
locked down
uh small outbreaks and so the small
outbreaks have turned into
uh surges if you like and i'm a bit more
optimistic than some of the modelers
because i think
this summer we will find that the
seasonal effects kick in people spend
more time outdoors
and hopefully we'll get down to such a
low level
that when new uh outbreaks
potentially occur later in the autumn or
early winter
we can jump on it very quickly but for
that we must have a better
test trace and isolate system which at
the moment to be honest is not really
working
yeah but the key to this then would seem
to be i mean there might be issues with
a
with test and trace there might be some
medical issues but it seems to be from
what you're saying with a sense of
optimism
that actually this is about us we need
to behave ourselves as locked down
as ease we need to follow the rules we
need to be sensible
and if we do that we're going to really
mitigate the possibility of this getting
considerably worse
yes that's true up to a point i mean i
think the public have behaved
magnificently i mean
everyone thought that the second this
second major
lockdown would would you know people
would transgress and they haven't
by and large and you're right but i
think also
i mean you know every country that has
locked this down
has had an army of people on the ground
i mean if you're fighting a war you need
an army and and we don't have that i'm
speaking to a public health director
just recently
um you should really have one contact
tracer for every 1500 population
which means in a district you would
expect to have 100
to 150 he had 19 and none of it was
funded
through the uh you know the 37 billion
for test and trace
so i think we need to transfer the
funding that we've got from
call centers and the like into local
public health teams
so that they can really lock down any
outbreaks as they occur
okay professor costello very good to get
your thoughts this morning
thank you so that's the sort of medical
view
if you like but of course today is the
day when things are getting a little bit
easier and a lot of outdoor sports
venues are reopening
and open air swimming is one thing which
is allowed mike wellington is a manager
at the hatha sage swimming pool
in the peak district good to see you
this morning i mean how busy are you
expecting things to get
uh very busy yeah we've we started
ticket sales last week
and we're already sold out for the first
week so we're expected to be very busy
yeah
well in terms of selling out then how
how does this work i mean what sort of
limits are you having to put on
the numbers you can allow into the pool
uh we'll we're working within on
government and swim england guidelines
so basically
our capacities are pretty much half for
all of our main sessions
um in terms of the financial side of
this
which you know the the the nitty-gritty
you've clearly been closed for a long
time what is happening are you having to
up the prices to try and recoup a bit of
money
uh we haven't up the prices no we
understand that it has been quite a
difficult time
during this period so um we are run by
parish council
and the parish council actually honored
the prices that
we set out in 2019 before all the
pandemic hit
so the fact you've got a with the next
week booked in is
great news do you think in terms of
people following guidelines when they're
in the water how difficult is that going
to be for you guys to police
uh it is very difficult for us to police
obviously we've got signage up and
everything like that to allow people
to tell people that they have to try to
socially distance with
whether they're on their own or whether
they're within their family group
um it can be very difficult but we try
our best to try to keep people as
separate as we can
i mean from your regular swimmers
what what have they told you about the
impact that
it's had on them not being able to get
out and do their normal exercise in the
pool
uh it's been we've had a lot of a lot of
communications with our local people
especially our regular swimmers it's
been very hard on them really
um we are a very community-based
facility um
it has been very difficult for them we
we're
we class ourselves a bit of a family
here so to not have
our regular people coming and using our
facility has been very upsetting
for us and for them but a bit of a sense
of light at the end of the tunnel now
fingers crossed yes hopefully things
will start going back if the road map
starts working then hopefully we'll be
back to normal relatively soon
fingers crossed mike good to talk to you
thank you
thank you very much i have to say i do
fancy a bit of a dip after all this talk
about lido's and getting in a pool and
what have you
still to come for you this morning the
taxi sharing company uber will allow
some uk
customers to request a zero emissions
car we'll talk to them in a few minutes
we're going to open with a midsummer
night's stream that incredible uh
story of magic uh just listening to your
last article it definitely feels like
we're being very overwhelmed by
uh this the world at the moment and we
need things to take us away from it and
transcend it so yeah
midsummer night's dream then we'll go
into romeo and juliet a pandemic play as
we know shakespeare was the plague
writer he knew
better than anyone what it was like to
write in these conditions and find ways
out of these conditions
and that's as much about laughter in
midsummer night's dream as it is about
loss and grief and injustice as we've
just been hearing about in these
in these plays and then into twelfth
night uh
and our touring company will come back
whether they'll get beyond bankside this
year it
remains to be seen but they'll be
working with the local community
and a brand new play based on of its
metamorphosis so very
uh consciously talking about how we
transform ourselves
um physically literally and
metaphorically out of this time
first and foremost how are we getting
audiences
and artists back into the theater safely
uh we'll obviously
have uh single flow traffic we'll
stagger start times
um but again just to go back to
shakespeare i think where we're lucky is
this is a writer that knew how to write
plays during the plague
um and he also knew how to take care of
audiences during the plague and one of
those ways
is as he says in romeo and juliet let's
keep these plays down to two hours
traffic
when he says two hours traffic he means
just the movement of the plays keep
those plays going keep people
entertained
um and also no intervals and i think
that's something that surprised people
that it's
uh the plays when intervals is obviously
a quite a a recent invention a very
unapologetically commercial invention
and i we all know that shakespeare would
definitely have approved of the bar
and definitely approved of the gift shop
but as we try and think about reducing
ways of
how are we reducing congregation and
making sure that we can keep people safe
so
again going back to the heart of what
those plays were about is
autonomy for the audience so you are
free to come and go as you please he
will make sure that he repeats
any important plot point so if you need
to leave to go to the toilet you go
or to go to the bar you go or to go and
buy your stamp or your
um your rubber or your badge you go and
then you come back and the play will
just keep
um or keep going
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertainment
podcast
for wherever you are welcome to the
safety rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all-out politics podcast
for the listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that reducing
pollution
outside of school can help stop toxic
air getting trapped in our classrooms
[Music]
sunshine and warmth will develop quite
widely over the majority of
england and wales today however
elsewhere will be cloudier
with some patchy rain over the north of
england and wales and heavy rain across
northwest
scotland but eastern scotland looks to
be mainly dry bright and warm and this
will be right at times and fairly warm
for islands and northern ireland too
so taking a look at the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being very high
most places are expected to remain
predominantly low on monday
however some isolated pockets of
moderate levels of four to six
may persist across the northern isles
the air quality report
sponsored by phillips air purifiers
now from today one of the biggest online
taxi firms will offer passengers in
london the option to always take a
zero emissions vehicle electric car
ubers say customers in the capital can
use that
at no extra cost well let's talk to uber
regional manager
jamie hayward who joins us good to see
you this morning why have you decided to
put this on the table
good morning um so we we're delighted to
announce that you know as restrictions
ease and cities start to start to open
um the uber green will be available in
london
uh allowing riders to select a fully
electric vehicle for the first time and
as you say as the trips will be priced
uh the same as uberx then as drivers
will also pay a lower service fee uh
we're hoping that that will encourage
more and more drivers to switch to an ev
so how many electric vehicles have you
have you got amongst your drivers there
because
are you going to find yourself
overwhelmed with demand pretty quickly
um we think there is going to be
some very very good demand at the moment
uh we have uh 1
600 evs in central london um
and you know that's up from around 100
when we launched the clean air plan
which is something we we put in place in
january 2019 to help
drivers save for an ev so that that plan
has now
helped drivers save 125 million
pounds uh in individual driving
savings accounts which means that the
average driver who has a savings account
can save up to 4 500 pounds on a vehicle
right i'm wondering if this is you know
a sort of company initiative that you're
trying to push for green credentials or
is this
custom customer demand driven or a bit
of both
it it's it's absolutely customer demand
driven i mean it's important to say that
today's announcement is the culmination
of
of almost three years of work that that
we've been
being doing uh in uber i've mentioned
the the clean air plan which we launched
in january
2019 we've also got a
number of commercial relationships such
as uh with bp's pulse
charging network which means that
drivers can get access to
charging points at lower prices and
we've also helped drivers move into
more affordable vevs by negotiating
discounts with companies
like nissan and kia so this is very much
the
the culmination of a lot of work from a
lot of people over a long time
just very briefly because i mean great
news for people in london who want to go
green in that way but
most people watching and not in london
they're around the rest of the country
so
when'd you spread this out
yeah so we are from today it's it's
being launched in london
um but actually it's part of uh an
important milestone on our way to
electrify our whole fleet in the uk so
we've made the commitment
to be fully ev in london by 2025 and
fully
ev across the uk by 2030 so uber
uber green will be rolling out to other
cities in the coming coming future
jamie good to talk to you this morning
thank you
you're very welcome thank you very much
now let's talk about the role that
policing is going to play in the easing
of restrictions which of course
all come in today i'm joined by the
national chair of the police federation
of england and wales john after good to
see you john
um are you clear in terms of
what the rules are that you are now
going to have to police
um good morning stephen ish which i know
is not the most helpful of answers
uh but yes we are we are reasonably
clear i i think the frustrating thing
for police officers who are out there on
the front line trying to
enforce this if they need to educate the
public
is that there's still an awful lot of
confusion as to what people can do and
that's why
i've been calling on both the uh the
prime minister and the and the leaders
of the devolved
governments to be absolutely crystal
clear in their messaging to the public
and to policing as to what's expected
because there's a difference between
legislation and guidance
guidance is not legally enforceable
people seem to think it is
but we are on the road to this easing of
lockdown which we all want
my concern is what happened last year
was
many people see this as you know the
floodgates are open and they can do
whatever they want which is simply not
the case we had clarification from the
minister
earlier this hour saying you know if we
if we wanted to travel
as i would from 300 miles up to the lake
district to
visit my parents as long as i stayed
outside and didn't go in the house and
followed those rules
you know i am free to travel the length
and breadth of the country now i mean
were you aware of that
yeah well it was guidance because the um
what was announced or what's been
announced today
is the the governments have said that
you should stay at home
um you should limit your travel but
that's not musk that's not legislation
and obviously within wales it's slightly
different so if you cross the border you
need to be aware
of the legislation over there because it
is slightly different
but yes you can you can travel and i
think many people don't
realize that now this isn't the police
saying what you can and can't do this is
the government this is legislation
what my colleagues have to do is
interpret that legislation which is not
always easy
um and engage with the public to to try
and make their lives
as positive as they can but it's not
always been easy
and certainly easing out of lockdown as
i've said uh creates its own problems
and it's it's the confrontation issue as
well isn't that i mean
there's these situations now where
there's the rule of six outside
all two families which may exceed six
i mean that puts police officers in a
very difficult position when they have
to go and approach people to find out
what on earth is actually going on
uh absolutely and let's not forget there
are still members of the public who are
making complaints to the police when
they see large groups
and that will continue and that's
because people are still concerned you
know there's still a
deadly virus out there that we're all
trying to play our part to minimize the
impact
so if police officers see large groups
uh out and about
then they could well engage with them
and ask them um you know if they're from
two households but it does get
incredibly
uh complicated and it's also really
intrusive because this is not the way
that
we want to police this is what we're
trying to do to keep everybody as safe
as possible
but it's certainly not easy and the vast
majority of the public get that and they
support us and they work with us to try
and make things
as as good as they can but some people
obviously will take advantage of the
situation
that's what we've seen i mean a lot of
this of course is driven by the fact the
vaccination program has worked so
incredibly well so far i mean 56 57
of the adult population have had their
first dose now police officers have not
been
put on a a sort of higher list if you
like
um does that you may say it wasn't fair
but does that
is anything that needs to be done now to
try and you know get police officers
vaccinated as soon as possible with this
continued interaction with the public
uh absolutely stephen and i'm putting
pressure on government
all the time to do the right thing look
what they're expecting
police officers to do go in and out of
people's homes to
to police large-scale events uh to sadly
deal with the
the deaths in people's homes uh people
who died
from covidon and other conditions
there's a risk there
and whilst the the the risk of death or
serious illness for my colleagues might
be
reduced because of age then they can
then become super spreaders themselves
and nobody wants that so i'm still
calling on the government to do the
right thing prioritize my colleagues
we've got some
large-scale events coming up um in the
coming months where
hundreds if not thousands of police
officers will be deployed around the
country
and yet none of them are being
prioritized for the vaccine
i just think it's it's a real betrayal
by the government
john we've got to leave it there but
good to talk to you thank you
this is sky news breakfast let's get a
check on the weather for you now
with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning we're now into british
summer time
and we've got lots of spring sunshine to
come with that as well it is going to be
increasingly sunny and
warm over the next few days but across
the far northwest it will be wet and
cold in fact
rain is going to persist across western
scotland and there will be the risk of
flooding issues there's the met office
do
also have a warning out for western
parts of scotland
because of that rain persisting and it
is there this morning and across the
northwest of ireland too some
patchy outbreaks across the northwest of
england and wales as well and it's a
fairly cloudy start this morning but
it's mild particularly across the north
where it is unfortunately rather windy
as well now by around midday we'll see
sunshine develop across southern areas
may stay quite cloudy though around the
south coast and quite cool there through
the day but inland there'll be more in
the way of sunshine and
it will be warming up as well and across
the rest of england worlds there will be
sunshine later as well but the northwest
these areas i think will hold on to
quite a bit of cloud with some patchy
light rain
and there will be a fair amount of cloud
cross island northern ireland the south
and east of scotland too but across
these areas the cad will break
and thin at times so there will be some
brightness about just not as sunny as it
will be
across the majority of england and wales
and it will become drier across
uh the northwest of ireland as that
rainbow shifts its way further
northwards up to the far northwest of
scotland heading towards the northern
irelands as we head into tonight so
still some very wet conditions there
through tonight and that rain band
continues to sink a little further
southwards into the northwest of maine
and scotland by dawn
uh for ireland northern ireland and
scotland quite cloudy the same two for
northern england
the rest of england the whales will be
clear chilly and frosty with some mist
and fog across the south but again
lots of sunshine for england wales and
later island tomorrow
the weather sponsored by qatar airways